jlo and mama lupe are dropping some
mother-daughter confessions
in this e.t exclusive
what have i learned from jennifer not a
darn thing no i'm okay
oh my mom i mean everything i do with my
mom
is really fun honestly even though she
drives me crazy like all our moms drive
us crazy
[Music]
oh also and i get all my my dance moves
from her
and here she is folks
[Music]
something that'll blow your mind jlo's
51 mom lupe is 74.
the two got together with twins max and
emmy in l.a to shoot coaches
holidays where you find it campaign
which is all about
family my mom is really the person who
instilled the love of music in me and
all my sisters
she was a young mom she got married when
she was 20. she had my sister when she
was 21.
she had all of us by the time she was 26
and so
we all grew up together it was like
living with a teenager to be honest
our e.t vault is full of moments where
j.lo has gushed about their close
bond my mom was a kindergarten teacher
they instilled in me that i could do
whatever i wanted to do if i worked hard
so you know it's their fault
she wanted us to be independent she
didn't want us to ever have to depend
on a on a man for anything because
that's what she was taught when she
grew up lupe is always in it that's her
middle name in it
i've watched her work from audience so
many times and now today's so special
because i got to work with her
[Music]
jennifer also revealed she gets all of
her energy and her drive
from her mama there is nothing like that
mother-daughter bond kev let me tell you
so really lupe is the real mvp
yeah basically she's the queen